[Music]
my name is it must be on their body and
personality
they're only going to show body parts
and have them talk but they'll do one
after the other it's kind of like that
show in the uk called naked attraction
the only difference they're going to be
closed
negative attraction was crazy show the
ankles then just push
that's why
just the yo if you guys have never seen
the naked attraction i'm pretty sure
it's naked attraction i think it's
called clear it out and another journey
we need to do this listen
you know you just see a puss didn't you
see the titties so you're just talking
with the [ __ ]
but
so what you like to do on the weekend
[Laughter]
uh-huh
yay
tell me more
what you doing oh i'm reading on her
lips
i would say my body type is someone
that's very slim
someone that keeps up with themselves i
i wouldn't say tall but just someone
around my around my height as long as
she's not like three or four feet taller
than me okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] you into lord of the rings
you you fantasy
yeah i'm not trying to date a tree
yeah i want a nine feet [ __ ]
hey
if you're out there and you're nine feet
ten
my bad my man trying to dunk to kiss a
[ __ ]
he's trying to follow michael jordan
every time come here
i don't want you to i don't want you to
sit on my face
i just want you to dip
hey you you talking [ __ ] but have you
ever ate a girl's [ __ ] while she's
standing
have you
read her lips
man
anyway shout out to him i think that's
why even the producers were like what
three to four feet that's like that's i
think he meant three to four inches
that's that's a lil wayne song
i did that time [ __ ] i french kissed
her
then what i do i french kiss her cause
he lips
[ __ ]
kiss that [ __ ] and you know she's smart
excuse me mr mister move so i can please
her nine foot [ __ ] all i'm in my face
up
first against the lips then i kiss the
lips
six foot seven foot hey
and you already know what that album is
gonna be called
the card or nine feet
the cut or not
no corrections no addendums
shout out to you man
[Music]
interesting
very interesting toes i'm gonna say
there are some people that do keep up
with their toes
there's also
some women who i feel like my toes look
a little bit better than
i'm gonna be honest so long as you ain't
got dirt underneath the nails i don't
really care though i won't front when
you got chipped nails like when you did
pedicures or like colored things and
they chipped all over i start to look at
you yeah either just go no nails or make
them dumb yeah keep them clean that's
all we ask
i will say though i start to think it
looks a little bit suddenly like i feel
like
i got nails that are better than some
people if you that's not what he did
that's not you going far
there's also
some women who i feel like my toes look
a little bit better than
six foot seven foot eight foot
that was just eight foot hey listen look
i just feel yeah i saw the hand i didn't
see the hand you got that
oh god i just feel listen listen there's
a couple of hand gestures that give me
such vibes if i see you doing this
this
okay if i see you sitting in a chair
viva la chair
people a chair yeah if you sit in a hand
you a little arch
you think
[Music]
how long did it take you to get over us
and what did you do to help yourself get
over it
you know what it is i'm gonna tell you
what it is okay i'll tell you what it is
you haven't even seen it but i'm gonna
tell you what it is this
is just like the sock from the other
video all right the hole in this sucks
this is what it is i'm gonna tell you
why you're cringing like that you
haven't seen it but this is why
when you sit in a foldable chair and
your butt is so far packed in the chat
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what is your ideal body type okay tall
bit
um
but not too big because i'm i'm kind of
a small person so not like you can kill
me listen if you're small we can all
kill you
let's keep it a stack with you okay but
i get it you don't want them steroid
type looking dudes i always think those
guys look funny when you see shaq with a
five foot two girl yeah it's just slack
my goddamn she's dying yeah
you haven't [ __ ] yet
why ha you know how i know
she's still walking she's still
breathing i do prefer somebody who's
taller than me the the most i'll go
shorter than me is like two inches um
i'm sorry babe not two feet but two
inches
shout out to imani she said listen and
she's the one that hit her feet whenever
he was looking at feet yeah
yeah that was a straight jack back yeah
she went she went she went she went
over hey
she said i might not win this
competition but you best believe i'm
gonna get my dub okay let's go i have
dated people of like all different
heights and body type so i don't
discriminate over here baby i mean she's
definitely getting eliminated i noticed
the tattoo bitter sweet and i gotta say
i really dig that thank you
are you i really dig that promise still
elimination
and you know what that's going to be
what better sweet
[Music]
going to have to eliminate number one
[Music]
nice to meet you too
i don't know they just they were the
only ones not really done
okay
that's weird okay okay so we already
know who the final two's gonna be on
this number
one
and
four
okay let's find out what happens
the same answer for you
so some are a little bit revealing and
others i see shorts yeah okay what's up
with the shorts um
my parents are going to watch this
shout out to you sister i get it you
know what i mean especially if you got
something yay i get it can't be out here
in a farm
but no i can't i'm going to put your
pom-pom out there no for people to see
for the people limited yeah put your
panties on there we're not even know if
the plenty is clear yeah no
i will i will not lie my parents
wouldn't have even let you get on the
show to begin with i mean
you showing your feet is haram you feel
what i'm saying so and hi parents yeah
this is like conservative i think for me
okay girl get it yeah
and then number five although there's a
lot of tattoos over there i like that
tattoo yeah i have like little kind of
random bangers all over like little
stick and poke style ones i'm a stripper
so i'm like in my underwear for a living
yeah i was about to say she got choked
me vibes
what huh
okay
sticking poke is definitely computer
yeah so this is also very conservative
for me okay yeah that's true for what's
you having clothes on period is
conservative
you're struggling yeah your strippers
what's your um favorite thing about
stripping money
i like the people
they have air conditioning
your favorite thing about prostitution
uh the john's
what do you like about stripping um
shout out to him you know free roses
my days here we go what do you like oh
the
freaks now there was someone earlier who
mentioned uh being thrown around
um hi christine is asian for sure
now
i have a personalized question for you
oh no what's your biggest turn on um
probably oh no i can't say that
i would just say like someone who cares
about pleasing the other person more
than themselves eat my butt
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was jimmy yeah that's what you mean
stop praying yeah but she won't say that
so she'll be like so how do you feel
about groceries right
how many am i eliminating this right now
[Music]
okay
two and five
[Music]
nice to meet you too i like your tattoos
thank you
we'll link up it's full yeah
damn this is hard as hell no it's like
this she's she's hot
she's hot damn that pants are kind of
nice now
number
all right two harm no foul it's okay
take care
i don't know you listen shout out to the
people who signed up to do this but yeah
yeah it takes a bit of a coincidence
i think asia's gonna win do you think
she's asian
number two she's not mexican
that's all they have in california
they have all of asia and mexico hey but
her nose she's asian
what does that key mean
it's the key to my heart yeah definitely
definitely asia there's no way the
mexican lady number one is going to win
the one the key with the heart
if she wins that's hot huh you want it i
might have to take that right now i'm
okay yeah you you prove it
i was about to you want it
you want it
do you want it
i actually moved out here from the east
coast with my ex at the time so put on
my best clown makeup and came out here
and it didn't
work out
it did not work out shout outs to you
that's my girl why because she she knows
but you live in strip clubs
huh
what is your support
what the [ __ ] did you say about me
yeah the way your face changed up mommy
what the [ __ ] did you say about me
that was perfect carry on you said i
live there yeah i do
um
what no that's my girl cuz
she knows she knows [ __ ] no no
i put my clown makeup they know when
what a [ __ ] can say i was a
clown what does it mean when they say
they put the clown makeup on that means
there was a clown okay they they did the
clown [ __ ] to do okay and then so she
she and she move and she fallen when she
shouldn't add and it didn't work out she
realized she realized
yeah i respect that
so the person i'm going to have to
eliminate unfortunately is number
three
[Music]
hi
you do have nice he has really has nice
eyes by the way he really thank you i
appreciate that
i like the hearts thank you i like the
heart shape but
i'm not even gonna front whenever i see
a bald headed woman i just think freak
because you have to have some balls to
cut off all that hair it's just
yo i respect that yeah i never met a
girl who was bothered in suck dick like
that never happened bro it's always the
long-haired women who try to have like
all that self-respect in the bedroom you
know what i'm saying really but ball
head women like y'all listen i already
cut off no let's do this let's do this
let's do this let's do this yeah yeah
yeah i guarantee you the likelihood of
her sucking some diggity ball or short
hair
is higher way higher
shortcut two a shortcut yeah girls like
the shortcuts cause it's out of the way
i never remember one that was virgin
that's never happened before
nah bro
yeah it's always the rapunzel types the
ones who never did the trips
i'm going to have to eliminate number
two
[Music]
hi hi christina kai nice to meet you to
meet you
[Laughter]
i don't know like he he's really
regretting his choice he's really
regretting his name yeah he seemed very
very shy i liked your answers yeah i got
like the same glasses as you do what's
your vision are you uh you're far sided
yo
yo yo
yo yo yo
uh beyonce to the left to the left you
got eliminated your ear you're not
trying to chit-chat and uh have a little
talk with the people damn you're here
see yourself out the way
go away you need figure talk about now
you have to have a conversation with
them with the man them no
get out
which mean
don't try to have a conversation now i
like your glasses i got your skedaddle
but christina you can holler at me cause
he does not no
but
bad [ __ ] is the only thing that you
like
you know what i'm saying like
nigga's always like yo where's your time
i'm like yo big small tall big thing i
don't care i am
near side where you can see right right
yeah can you give me a game again you
want to take much yay
girl girl
i respect that you running game but have
some self respect you know what it is
give me give me me
five six yeah yeah
like you gonna dm you know
[Applause]
like 3d huh it's like a little stronger
than mine so yeah yeah oh i don't know
i'm sorry don't be fiery you're good
put the glasses back on can you see
let's see what you said no too like oh
yeah i would you should have done that
that's what you should have done like
the great mini man said
you're lost
it was nice meeting you thank you
[Music]
gas and on electricity yeah yeah that's
what i meant
and i like your answers as well
especially with the key to the hard
thing that one no
ah you recording [ __ ] too
nah bro let me turn this [ __ ] [ __ ]
off do you like that
that's not your problem see my phone
said no we ought to use this my phone's
still falling here right
it's falling and it can't get up but you
know what what your phone is just like a
lisa cheese i
all right
let's you guys do whatever you guys want
to do be happy shout out to you some
people like corny and who am i to hate
you know what i'm saying it's not my
relationship it's not a problem but
oh the
shout out to all the contestants i think
doing that on camera would you be very
uncomfortable i think you have all the
different body types i think it's really
dope that they wanted to do that and put
themselves out there because i know a
lot of other folks would feel
uncomfortable doing that he's all around
christina later on i'm i'm here
you know what i'm saying really no yes
no yes you're gonna find her you know
the contestants over there that show
like 20 [ __ ] am i going to do a 20 year
old
yeah yeah
what are you gonna say she looks she
look twenty twenty twenty five twenty
something twenty one out there points yo
uh if you like this subscribe hit the
like button just all last we have a
patreon and another channel called abba
versus priest go go go go check it out
abba versus preach yeah